what's going on reject nation that's a
wrap up the defenders finally so I've
got two more episodes left gonna do a
full like series review where the Andrew
after I'm done you know the drill let's
do this [ __ ] head shake bothers whole
lecture versus iron fist
[Music]
nice madam yeah
madam down damn
your kicks daredevil nice been judges
stunt double is great
[Music]
Madame GAO's the coolest hoarding this
whole fight
[Music]
[Music]
nice I don't know why that guy ever
thinks he has a chance
[Music]
she is to pick a badass in this fight
man this guy's sucks
[Music]
alright Colleen
[Music]
yeah I'm really not a fan no way this
fights directed whoa whoa but they they
prepare for that all right Paige putting
out the fire if I could have been cooler
in some ways you know
okay okay hey you should be the precinct
well welcome
Luke ages sexes now I know that's not
what's really going on dandy red keeps
getting his ass kicked
[Music]
[Music]
our pistol storage is an auto repeat
this hole
[Music]
oh he's gonna cheat up yep there it is
there it is
[Music]
now time damn dude so uh quick thoughts
on this episode do you really love it
fight scene I know towards the end of
this I thought was some cool stuff
Madame Gao kicked a lot of ass
Daredevils cool I didn't like that I
wasn't a fan of the way was directed
though man it was too much editing too
much cutting I could I can tilt the
hell's going on a lot of the time
there's more like Iron Fist season 1
action than daredevil season 1 and 2
action went I know I figure if you're
gonna do defenders with Iron Fist being
complained about so much with its action
scenes that I you would think that they
would go more towards what daredevil
fight teens did as opposed to iron fist
but whatever it's just one element shown
as some stuff I liked in the episode I
like the inclusion of misty Knight here
and though and the role she's playing
you know she kind of just disappeared in
the early part of this season I heard
she's gonna be an iron fist season 2 and
with the way how she's getting like
comfortable with the vigilantes I feel
like they were really setting her up for
the daughters of the Dragon storyline I
also appreciate how the show's making
her that cop character for the heroes
you know the cop that the heroes could
talk to the one the cop that can get in
trouble for being friends at the
vigilantes okay so I know there's a lot
of [ __ ] going on in this last episode
well Matt did have his minor breakdown
over 6 death I can't help but feel there
should have been a little more grieving
to Styx death which will probably occur
more in season 3 of daredevil and
surprisingly one of the standout scenes
to me in this episode was the scene with
Matt and foggy in the hallway at the the
police precinct you know were foggy he's
given his foggy speech back met being
frickin mad but ultimately he shows a
little support by giving Matt the
daredevil costume that was a nice touch
when at realizes like Oh
foggy hooked up the costume that
[ __ ] but to be perfectly
transparent I just didn't love this
episode I didn't it wasn't all that
exciting it plays out a little
conventional from for my taste and it is
starting to feel really cheesy very
cheesy I just don't think the hand is
all that scary especially with how a
lecture is calling the shots now and she
doesn't even really see much it gives a
[ __ ] about the hand yet they built up
the hands so much with some characters
of daredevil season 1 a lot of talk
about the hand
during season two and then all
throughout our fifth season one and then
the entirety of the defenders but it
just doesn't seem like these dudes are
all that impossible to defeat not even
the main fingers of the hand seem that
hard to defeat Madame gala seems like
the toughest cookie I feel like
daredevil and Luke Cage could probably
do all the hard work themselves yeah I
just doesn't seem like they need to rely
on Jessica Jones or Iron Fist for that
matter he just keeps getting his ass
kicked what I found really upsetting was
the fight scene in this episode it's
like it sets it up for a really cool
fight but by the end of it I'm I'm left
with all these feelings of the hand
isn't seen that intimidating and the
fight choreography and the way it's
being directed just isn't that cool it's
like beyond it's editing it's really the
stakes the stakes are not really felt
like the fingers of the hand that
they're fighting in that scene that Luke
Cage Daredevil and Jessica Jones are
fighting they don't seem that hard to
defeat in the Japanese guy whose name I
don't remember he they set him up like
he's gonna be this super badass lethal
warrior but every scene he gets his ass
attitude
I feel like Finn Jones I've been liking
Finn Jones as acting but I feel like in
this episode if he's not with Luke Cage
or the other defenders his acting just
digresses again and I like the actress
of what I think her name is Elodie young
I might be wrong about that I like the
actress who plays Elektra and I like
what she's doing with the material
that's being written for her but but the
writing of her it still feels cheesy and
generic and the fight scene with a light
turn on her face that was cool I don't
know overall this episode just felt kind
of a letdown
especially after there's such good
moments of episode 6 with such a strong
impact was like the last 15 minutes of
that episode it's just really starting
to feel like they're trying to wrap this
all up because they only got eight
episodes for the season and not you know
13s already feeling like maybe they
could have used just like nine episodes
but not a good number so maybe 10 anyway
I'm gonna watch the last episode now if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects you can
click that notification bell follow me
at the greg alba on instagram and
twitter and of course you know become a
patron eject today by checking out our
patreon